[Music]
got all right it's October 19th 2023 I'm
Dave rubben this is the Ruben report
we're live streaming in all the usual
spots if you're watching this I hope you
know what you're doing uh we're doing
something a little different today
because joining me right now I'm not
calling him a guest I'm going to call
him a co-host for the next 45 minutes or
so is an old friend who I cannot believe
it my guys just told me has not been on
the show since July of 21 so over two
years ago which is just nuts uh Ben
Shapiro a man who needs no introduction
welcome to the Reuben report
uh thanks for having me Ben uh I wish we
were talking under better circumstances
obviously we chat now and again about
world events offline um but before we
dive into any of the craziness the
Insurrection yesterday the lies of the
New York Times and MSNBC and we can
obviously talk about some of just sort
of the general demon likee barbarity and
all of that I guess man how are you
doing how you doing you know people have
been asking me that for the last couple
of weeks and my usual answer is
irrelevant question I mean everybody's
doing horrible I that's the answer we
have lots of friends and family in a
Harm's Way many of our friends and
family in Israel have spent the last two
weeks doing nothing but Shiva calls
people who have been trying to raise
resources for new orphans new widows
people who have been sifting through the
actual wreckage at at many of these
sites around the Gaza envelope where
they are still finding bits of bone from
children uh so yeah I mean it's been an
incredibly difficult time for for
everybody you know we're lucky in the
sense that you know we're safe and our
kids are fine um but the fact is that
even the upsurge in sort of open-faced
anti-Semitism around the world is is
pretty threatening to to pretty much
everybody that I know and interact with
and uh it's it's been disturbing to say
the least I did not think this is
something I would see in my lifetime and
certainly not something my parents
thought that they would see within their
lifetime it's the worst attack on Jews
since since the Holocaust and the
response has been pretty um I think it's
been a pretty good rebuttal to the idea
of never again there there are a lot of
people who when they say never again
really what they mean is is sure again
just as long as I can avoid culpability
so how do you gauge how much actual hate
there is because my general feeling and
it's hard to quantify this obviously is
that actually most of America most of
the western world most of civilized
people they stand with Israel they want
Jews to be equal citizens in their
countries like all of the things that
that America has been about yet there is
this ridiculously vocal minority it it
comes from something we used to call the
regressive left years ago and it's born
BN out of the woke stuff and now we have
the Hamas caucus and all that and
they're loud and we're going to show
some video of what they were up to
yesterday but I don't think it
represents most people but it does
that's not to diminish the threat and
the institutional power that it has but
how do you gauge that versus just the
the average person who's confused about
the issues or refuses to take a stand
that kind of thing I mean I think that
really there there's sort of four
categories here so category one is the
Kamas caucus and its followers and that
is a a small but incredibly vocal
minority disproportionately represented
certain places in the United States like
Dearborn Michigan obviously where they
had Mass rallies in favor of
Hamas category two is people who just
don't know anything uh and uh and and
really don't follow this sort of stuff
and so they just tend to believe
whatever the media tells them and the
easiest offramp for them is cycle of
violence don't know what's happening
there's an intractable conflict or
remain an intractable conflict don't
care hands up whatever uh that that's
group number two I would say that that
group is you know moderately sized
because a lot of Americans don't follow
International Affairs all that much
group three is are people who are
innately symp athetic to the state of
Israel in its fight against Islamic
terrorism but who are questionable in
whether they will actually allow Israel
to do what it needs to do to defend
itself uh and that is a larger group I
would say that that that group is again
a lot of Democrats who are are showing
right now that they're pro Israel but
the question is for how long until until
what until until Israel actually has to
take the sorts of actions that do result
in more death in the Gaza Strip until
Israel has to bomb the tunnel systems
that are being shielded with civilians
so for how long is the question for that
group and then there's the fourth group
which is I think still the largest group
in the United States is certainly the
largest group in the Republican party
and that group of people who say yeah
Israel is fighting an existential evil
terrorist force and it needs that that
Israel should be given full leeway to do
whatever it needs to do to rid the world
of these pieces of of human debris so
you know if I had to break those down
percentage wise I would say that like
the number of people who are in the full
pramas Camp is somewhere between five
and 10% of the American population the
group of people who are in the full
pro-israel Camp is probably 35% of the
American population so that's 45%
together so now we have to split up the
other 55% between the people who just
don't know and the people who know but
are kind of wishy-washy I would say the
people who just don't know of that 55%
it's probably 25% people who just don't
know enough don't care enough don't
don't want to pay attention to it and
30% are in the sort of wavering category
pro-israel but could fall off the wagon
in any moment which means that if my
stats are correct and this is kind of
what the the stats are showing right now
basically two-thirds of the American
population is pro Israel but maybe 40%
of that is kind of waveringly pro Israel
in the sense that the minute that Israel
starts to take the measures it has to
take which inevitably going to be ugly
and are going to cause loss of life you
could see a serious movement ground
swell begin against Israel doing the
things needed to to actually rid the
world of Kamas sure you know
interestingly I don't find those numbers
that depressing actually because you're
what you're basically saying is there's
a chunk of people who either don't know
or kind of on the fence and I think if
they see more of the barbarity if they
hear more of the statements and they see
the craziness uh and we also tell them
the truth which is what I'm desperately
trying to do on this show I know you're
out there doing it and many other people
that that hopefully they'll wake up why
do you think that no other country on
earth is subjected to these ridiculous
rules that Israel is subjected to so as
you said this is the worst attack on
Jews since the Holocaust I mean the
things are just the burned babies the
raped women all all of this stuff um and
yet only Israel gets like a 48 hour
window on what they can do and the
amount of people who immediately turn on
them and everything else is that does
that also go back to the fundamental
misunderstanding of the land the
connection of Jews to this place and and
all of that so I think there are a bunch
of reasons for it I think number one
obviously there's a really thorough
undercurrent of anti-Semitism to the
idea that the Jews don't have the
ability or the power or shouldn't have
the ability or power to defend
themselves from monstrous jew-hating
genocidal terrorists that that is pretty
obvious if at this point you are
sympathetic to Hamas or to the pro
Palestine movement which seems unable to
dissociate from Hamas then I think it's
pretty clear where that is coming from
so that is definitely an undercurrent
the fact that Israel is held to a
standard that no other country is held
to is absolutely insane and so you
obviously there's an anti-semitic
undercurrent there's also a a very
strong overcurrent I would say it's
pretty obvious of just denialism people
who don't want to believe what is in
front of their eyes and so what they've
done is they've created a construction
in their mind where Hamas Palestinian
Authority Islamic Jihad most people
there are actually Western liberals like
us like underneath they're actually
Western liberals who just want material
prosperity and they want good lives for
their kids and the way that we Define a
good life for our kids in individual
rights and freedoms this is the sort of
George W bush 2004 UN speech where every
human heart yearns to beat free and all
this kind of thing and so they look at
this and they say okay well but that's
probably a minority it's probably like a
small group of people and so if Israel
is just if they make a few more
concessions if they're a little nicer if
if Israel doesn't doesn't actually hit
civilians in an attempt to to hit
military targets or anything then maybe
everything will be okay and that's a
comforting myth that a lot of people
believe it's also a comforting myth
because that that we can afford in the
west because frankly the West is not
located directly in the middle of the
Islamic world I mean Israel is is
surrounded on all sides by countries
with populations that are genocid Jew
hating I mean there's there's just no
question about that by every available
poll that is the case it may not be
politically correct to point out that
the Palestinian population not just the
leadership the Palestinian population
hates Jews but that happens to be the
reality which is why there are giant red
signs off the side of the road in Israel
that say if you drive into this
Palestinian City you may be killed I
mean that's literally giant road signs
like you would to get off a freeway that
are on the side of the roads in Hebrew
and English and Arabic to Jews saying do
not go off this road into this
Palestinian area we can't guarantee your
life certainly Palestinian mistakenly
drives into Israel they just have a nice
day on mamila or whatever but if if if a
Jew drives into rala very good shot that
jewi isn't coming out again everybody
knows this this is not any sort of
secret but in the west because we don't
live CH and jow with radical
fundamentalist populations it's easy for
us to to just imagine a world in which
well you know if we live next to them
they would probably be nice people I
mean they're just people just like us
again that that is the the conceit of
Western Civilization it's it's a western
civilization is unique and US pretending
that Western Civilization actually
speaks for the entire world that
everybody has our mindset incredibly
dangerous stuff you're seeing it
materialized by the way in Mass
migration from a lot of these radical
fundamentalist countries into the West
which is why you're seeing 50,000 people
on the Streets of London chanting in
favor of Kamas so how do you think we
extricate ourselves from that mistake in
thinking because it seems like that that
is the basic Western position again I'm
not calling anyone a racist or a hater
or an anti-semite or anything else that
but basically we have had it so good in
the West for so long we cannot imagine
what it would be like to have people
thankfully can't imagine what it would
be like to have people run into our
house and kill our children and rape our
women or have I think 7,000 Rockets
which are still being fired at this very
moment like how do we how do we sort of
shift the thinking so that people can
realize boy not everybody is kind of as
nice as us and if you're just nice to
them they're going to be nice to you I
think the only thing you can do is show
the images it's one of the reasons why I
I've been showing actual pictures of and
footage of the atrocities because what
that says to people is these people are
not like you and they're not you what
what would it take for you to go into a
random civilian home and burn their baby
in their crib and the answer is
literally nothing on Earth would make
you do that because you're a Westerner
but that is not the case obviously with
Hamas terrorists by the way it's not the
case with some of the Hamas the Hamas
Associated civilians one of the one of
the more shocking things that's been
coming out in recent days is how many
civilians from Gaza who are not open
Kamas members actually flooded into
these Jewish areas and participated in
the rape and the murder and the Looting
I mean that there's footage GoPro
footage from Kamas of civilians like 14
15y old kids who are running in and
doing this sort of stuff and again that
comes from a deep well of anti-Semitism
that has been indoctrinated in kids for
Generations in these areas and that
again the West has wanted to ignore
while by the way funding those same
institutions the the United Nations rwa
the UN RW is the refugee Association
that's basically designed for the
Palestinians their schools teach Jew
hatred genocidal Jew hatred and that's
funded by the United States I mean again
we have a fundamental disconnect in the
West only way to to disabuse ourselves
of that is to come face to face with it
we're lucky in the United States we
haven't had to come face to face with
that we're very far away from this
region of the world thank God uh the
same thing is true in in Europe although
Europe is is starting to face up to it a
little bit more because of the large
radical Islamic fundamentalist
population that that is in places like
London 15% of London is Muslim a huge
percentage of that are people who are
who are Jew haters you know people
people are beginning to see that in some
of these areas um but you again the only
way is just to remind people over and
over and over again for a brief moment
in time the American people tend to
realize these things after 911 the
American people realized hold up a
second you mean there are people out
there who don't think like us and then
the media jumped in and said we can
never show these images again you
remember this after 911 it was it's too
damaging to the psyche it's too
traumatic we can't see the images of the
man jumping from the 88th story of the
World Trade Center because it might
incite islamophobia it might it might
make people more Angry it might make
make people think of of you know
terrorists as the other terrorists are
the other okay there are very few people
in humanity who are the other people are
not the other based on race but people
can certainly be the other based on you
know support for genocidal Jew hatred do
you know do you remember this that after
911 there was an episode of The Simpsons
where they went to New York City and
Homer runs up both Twin Towers it's
obviously before 911 and then they took
it out of syndication because they just
didn't want people thinking about it
like that's the level of sort of the
cultural rot that we have that we've
remove comedies in the name of whatever
it is multiculturalism or whatever else
I want to ask you one other kind of Blue
Sky thing and then we can dive into
what's gone on the last couple days do
you think in a weird way you know
there's been I don't know probably 20 40
50 of us publicly uh doing what kind of
what we do that have been screaming
about identity politics talking about
this intersectional calculator and how
it pushes Jews out because Jews are a
minority that generally has been
oppressed and and programmed and
Holocaust it across the world but is now
thought of as successful do you think in
a weird way we all failed because we
then watched wokeism infect all our
institutions get the Hamas caucus
elected uh lead to not knowing whether
boys or girls and and not knowing
whether borders should exist like the
whole damn thing that a bunch of us were
talking about and warning about and were
called alt-right for yesterday on my
show I showed that front page article
from The New York Times you remember it
well where they called us leaders of the
alt-right uh years ago um do you think
in a weird way we we failed or or was
this obviously going to happen not the
barbarity specifically but the the sort
of point that we're at Society I mean I
I think that we we failed in the sense
that obviously we didn't prevent what
what happened and we haven't prevented
the spread of this sick ideology the
intersectional ideology that is making
excuses for Kamas right now because
that's really what it is the the Karen
ATA well this is what decolonization
looks like the BLM support for for the
for for Kamas now all of that is is part
of a piece and and some of us have been
screaming at the top of our lungs about
this for literally our entire careers I
mean I was writing columns back in 2004
2005 2006 when I was like 20 years old
about the threat that posed in and the
the differences in in culture and the
educational system in these areas and
then as soon as woke reared its ugly
head which really began after the
election of Barack Obama in 200 in 2008
the the sort of woke movement really
began in Earnest in maybe 2010 2011 and
certainly in the runup to the 2012
election many of us were screaming about
that saying that this entire ideology
which basically says that there is a
group of dispossessed peoples who can
form a coalition together against the
white Overlord and that that group of
dispossessed peoples unites all of the
marginalized right it's the Palestinians
on the one but it's black people in the
inner cities on the other it's lgbtq
people on the one hand and it's
Democratic socialists of America on the
other and they're all part of one big
group to tear down the institutions
never mind the fact that if ever the
kosnik got the lgbtqs alone in a room it
would end with blood
obviously Palestine is very different
than Palestine for gays yeah that that's
exactly right you but that none of that
mattered and and I think that you're
seeing the wages of that today you know
again it it's it feels like the the
gaslighting is so strong wrong at this
point that that it's absolutely
maddening um and some people are are
waking up to it you I have liberal
Jewish friends who are suddenly waking
up to the fact that they're not part of
the intersectional Coalition they spent
years denying that they weren't part of
it oh well you know they're just
anti-zionists they're not anti-semites
oh well you know sure BLM is saying that
it's in favor of Palestine but they
don't mean they're against Jews they're
just they're just intersectional peoples
and and now they're realizing that well
you know too little too late I'm glad
that you're doing it I would be I'd be
glad if you guys would would recognize
uh who who are the people who actually
hate you but yes I mean in in terms of
has the West lost I mean there's no such
thing as a permanent Victory and so I I
think that this can be the beginning of
a western realization this could be the
beginning of the West getting truly
awakened right woken in in the proper
sense where the West realizes that its
civilization is under threat that
happens once apparently every 20 years
or so people wake up briefly and then
they go right back to sleep we can only
hope that this time uh this horror show
can can reawaken people to some extent
man I know I don't have have to tell you
this of all people but you know that the
uh the phone does not ring and you don't
get the apology from the people that are
waking up but I guess having them wake
up in and of itself I was I went to get
guns the other day a couple more guns
actually and the the owner first off
basically everyone in the store was was
Jewish and talking about what was going
on and the guy said to me we're selling
more guns right now than than we ever
have except for the first week of coid
so so I guess that would would you at
least consider that a degree of a silver
lining that maybe some people are are
kind of up I mean that's particularly
true again in the Jewish Community
everybody that I personally know in the
Jewish Community is is seeking to buy a
gun seeking to increase their protection
and I think that's a good thing for all
law-abiding Americans to do regardless
of race or religion but certainly Jewish
Americans feel threatened and they
should feel threatened by a movement
that has allies in very very high places
I mean as you were mentioning earlier
there is an actual Hamas caucus in the
United States Congress and they're given
cover by a media that lies on behalf of
Hamas it's incredible all right well
that's a perfect segue to what's gone on
for the last couple days so yes there
was an Insurrection yesterday I have no
problem calling it an Insurrection
because that's what they've called
everything that anyone who they don't
like uh does uh here is video of the DC
Capital
[Music]
[Applause]
yesterday
all right so there's obviously way more
video there's plenty of people being
arrested and everything else but in
essence they storm the capital I see
virtually no difference between this and
January 6 or anything else we do know
that the one difference will be how they
treat these people um Ben before we get
into the Hamas caucus specifically and
and Rashida uh who I think I think has
taken over from AOC as the the lead
General on that thing are are you amazed
how quickly they flipped BLM into a
pramas movement I mean it seems like
they just have a switch and when they
want to turn on these clone soldiers
they can just send them out and they'll
do whatever they want well again that's
the beauty of the intersectional
Coalition I mean why why would you
possibly think that BLM would suddenly
flip in favor of Kamas and the answer is
because there's a back scratching deal
if you support our cause we'll support
your cause our cause is really all the
same which is hatred of the West I mean
that that's really what all this comes
down to Israel is just in area of the
West in this particular Viewpoint it's
it's it's not even that Israel is a
place of particular hatred it's sort of
the tip of the spear it's the canary and
the coine as people like to say but but
it's it's not as though they hate Israel
sort of only that that Israel is the
only point of contention Israel is just
the most convenient point of contention
and the place where they can also build
the largest Coalition because again
Israel is Jewish and there are a lot of
people who really really hate Jews
there's only one state on Earth where
people actually require it to
consistently explain its own existence
that is the state of Israel it's the
only place on Earth where where people
demand justification for why there's a
Jewish State there are 55 Islamic States
no one has ever asked why Pakistan and
Islamic State or or Afghanistan or Iran
or Iraq or any of these other any of the
other country so they're picking a
convenient point of uh of of sort of
Coalition and coalescing but yes I mean
it it flips it flips purposes it goes
directly from rallies about trans women
our women to this in like a heartbeat
and it's and it's amazing it's the exact
same people they just they just take off
their t-shirt put on a new t-shirt and
then and then go to the capital building
and make trouble like this so yeah I
mean that that that's that's the entire
coalitional deal again not a shock it's
why that Harvard student letter that had
303 organizations on it including things
like the pan pan Asian-American
Coalition why do you think they're on
there you think they care about this
they don't care about this but they're
part of the same Coalition yeah it's so
psycho it's like psychotic and also
obvious which is a weird combination I
suppose but now since we've mentioned
her once or twice Rashida Talib
congresswoman from Michigan who is from
Dearborn Michigan which basic I mean
they held I think I have no problem
saying in essence it was a modern-day
Nazi rally last week I mean it was
absolutely insane no one is making the
distinction there was not one person
there who made the distinction between
the Palestinian flag and the actions of
Hamas not one person I mean can you
imagine one guy raising his hand and
being like guys actually Hamas went a
little too far they they would love to
take him out too anyway here she is
yesterday uh inciting the Insurrection
and also lying about the uh the bombing
of the hospital which we'll get to in a
moment continue to watch people think
it's okay to bomb a
hospital with
children you know what's so hard
sometimes is watching those videos and
and the people telling the kids don't
cry I'm like let them
cry and they're shaking and somebody you
know this they keep telling them not to
cry in
Arabic they just they can cry I can cry
we all can cry if we're not crying
something is
wrong and so I'm telling you right
now President Biden not all America's
with you on this one and you need to
wake up and understand that we are
literally literally watching people
commit
genocide Ben uh did she pump out any of
those crocodile tears for the babies
that were burned or the women that were
raped or Holocaust Survivors that are
now kidnapped or the I don't know say 20
plus American hostages I could go on she
she doesn't even pump out those tears
for Palestinian civilians who are killed
the the reason that you know this is
because she's still telling the lie that
Israel bombed the hospital so for
example it's it's kind of an an obvious
point but one that that is pretty
amazing when you think about it so for a
hot second Kamas puts out propaganda
that Israel has bombed a hospital
killing 500 people in the Gaza Strip and
that is implausible from the start if it
were to be a deliberate bombing
specifically because Israel for example
has not blown up the alifa hospital
which everyone knows literally everyone
knows sits on top of the Kamas military
headquarters and has for a decade
everyone knows this alifa is still
standing because Israel does not wish to
kill hundreds of civilians Israel is
doing its utmost I mean really its
utmost not to kill civilians the truth
is that if Israel were doing everything
it militarily had to do right now
there'd be a lot more civilians dead not
just because they'd be bombing buildings
but because the tunnels are where the
Kamas Fighters are hiding and they are
all hiding under civilian areas Israel
knows this they're not using their the
ordinance on those tunnels specifically
because Hamas is shielding those tunnels
with civilians in any case just real
wait wait just pause for one second
because the truth I think it's a point
worth reiterating because the truth is
they could end this in in three days
basically if they wanted if they wanted
to do the unimaginable to defend their
citizens they could end this basically
in three days if they wanted to do all
of the things that you're making the
point superiority they have the
ammunitions to do it if Israel wanted to
destroy every single tunnel not even
knowing where they're mapped if they
want to destroy all this tunnel and bury
the Kamas terrorists under Rubble they
could do that it would take an awful lot
of Civilian casualties which is why
they're not doing it and also why Hamas
is hiding civilians at top their tunnels
that's literally the reason Hamas is by
by its own behaviors admitting that
Israel seeks to avoid civilian
casualties that's that's why they put
the civilians there if they if they
thought that Israel was just out to kill
civilians wouldn't matter where the
civilians are they'd be trying to save
their own civilians by separating the
military fighters from the civilians
they're doing the opposite so the the
the news goes out that that Israel has
supposedly done an air strike on on a
hospital and 500 are dead it goes out
with them like five minutes they've got
the dead counted never mind that Israel
is still two weeks later trying to
figure out precisely how many people are
dead in the October 7th
massacres Kamas knew within five minutes
the entire world media pumps this out
they they all pump it out and it's all
atrocities look what Israel did and then
it turns out the New York Times runs a
full front page photo of the wrong
building of a different building
suggesting that that was the hospital
that was blown up and then it turns out
that it was a Palestinian Islamic Jihad
rocket that fell short because like 10%
of the rockets that are fired fall into
Gaza because they don't give it any
bleeps about their own citizens
obviously and um and it hit a it didn't
hit the hospital it hit a parking lot
next to the hospital and the actual
number of dead is probably not 500 is
probably we're now finding out maybe 10
to 50 uh it doesn't matter the the the
entire world goes insane I mean
conflagrations everywhere things on fire
giant protest and rashita Talib out
there oh my God the babies oh my God the
babies when it comes out as it already
has that it was a Palestinian Islamic
Jihad rocket that hit a that that hit
even if it had hit a hospital and killed
500 people her move would then not be
why is Palestinian Islamic Jihad firing
rockets that kill civilians in Gaza it
would be this never happened it would be
this is not important anymore I'm not
going to talk about this right it exits
the front page the minute right that it
can't be blamed on the Jews it exits the
front page that's how you know all this
is crocodile tear to be clear she not
only absolutely I mean she knows she's
repeating it yesterday after it's been
debunked it's been Community noted the
New York Times as we covered yesterday
changed their headline on it three times
uh you made the point that they showed a
a picture under the headline on the
front page of the New York Times that
was not the hospital it hit a parking
lot but I want to show you because
you're making the point of how quickly
the media just takes hamas's word Hamas
say something and then the media the
corporate press just repeats it here's
MSNBC reporting what we now know to be a
complete lie but the Palestinian Health
Ministry is saying a hospital in Gaza
City in the northern end of Gaza has
taken a direct hit from an Israeli air
strike they are saying hundreds at
minimum 300 people have been killed in
this strike now we have not yet heard
any comments about this allegation from
the Israeli military but these images
that are coming out of Gaza City are
absolutely
harrowing Ben how do we explain to
people that when they say the
Palestinian government or the
Palestinian Health Ministry they're
talking specifically about Hamas and as
you laid out they want as many dead
civilians or at least the idea of dead
civilians as possible I mean they're
Liars this is the part that's
astonishing you're literally taking the
word of the people who committed a
genocidal Massacre of Jews five minutes
ago and you're pretending that they tell
you the truth on these matters now we
know for a fact that Kamas lies about
this stuff on the routine they do it
routinely in 2014 the New York Times
admitted that Hamas their health
Ministry their so-called Health Ministry
lies routinely about casualy casualty
statistics The Washington Post reported
the same thing if you are a reporter in
the Gaza Strip you're only there because
Hamas is allowing you to be there what
that means that if you don't say what
Kamas wants you to say they will either
expel you or they will kill you everyone
knows this in the Gaza Strip and yet
they take at face value the the the the
proclamations of an actual honest to God
terror group and then when it turns out
that every element of the story is false
the it was a Palestinian Islamic Jihad
rocket it did not hit a hospital it hit
the parking lot next to the hospital
doing no actual structural damage to the
hospital itself when every single
element of the story turns out to be
false the media then say well you know
the story is now being contested it's
not being contested you guys blew it and
not only did you blow it you blew it for
a very particular reason which is you
were eager you were eager for a story of
an Israeli atrocity that you could use
to juxtapose with what happened on
October 7th so you could go right back
to your moral equivalence nonsense
thereby exacerbating all conflict in the
Middle East and getting more Jews and
Arabs killed by the way because when
conflict arises in the Middle East just
Jews that are getting killed Jews then
have to go in and kill the bad guys and
that means that a lot of innocent people
are going to die what do you make of
this farce where when she's putting out
those crocodile teers that Rashida TB is
also immediately demanding for a
ceasefire she has not once demanded that
the American hostages be released but
demanding for a ceasefire well I mean
obviously the ceasefire would be in
hamas's interest I mean if if the way
that this this magic goes is that you
get to murder 1500 Jews kidnap 200
Israelis including Americans and then
declare a ceasefire well you can see
exactly how that might benefit Hamas
that that is why ilhan Omar and AOC and
the entire Kamas caucus have decided for
a ceasefire immediately now listen in
America we all know how stupid this is
after 911 if somebody had said you know
what a lot of civilians are going to get
killed we got to call ceasefire with the
Taliban and Al-Qaeda we we we just can't
I mean there too there's going to be
some some too much human cost we have to
declare a ceasefire before anything else
bad everyone would look at that person
like they're absolutely out of their
mind or on the side of al-Qaeda and the
Taliban well as it turns out Rashida
Talib is on the side of Kamas she's been
on the side of Kamas for years many of
her supporters are open Kamas andah
supporters she's made no bones about
this she is called for the destruction
of the state of Israel she does not
believe in a two-state solution for
example she has called for the existence
of one secular state by secular State
she means an Arab State because
obviously the minute that Israel allows
for a mass influx of radical Muslims
into its voting population Israel turns
into an Islamic State all the Jews are
killed or pushed into the sea everybody
knows that this is the case now I was
asked a question last night at
University of Florida I spoke there last
night and some girl got up there and she
said well why why shouldn't there be
like a bational state and I said to her
okay you look like a a nice young
liberal woman there are 330 million
Americans should the United States for
the sake of open borders liberalism and
cultural diversity import from the
Middle East some 300 million Middle East
Eastern radical Muslim men and women to
vote would that be a good would you be
in favor of that and she obviously said
no or avoided the question because
that's what Rashid tbba is asking for
and we know why she's asking for that of
course right and Rashid TB is a Jew
hater we all know this this is not a
giant shock ilhan Omar is a Jew hater
AOC is is an adjunct to the Jew haters
and the only the only reason I'm not
calling her a Jew hater outright AOC is
simply because I think she's too stupid
to even understand what she's doing that
lady has the IQ of a cquad yeah well
we've played a bunch of Clips in the
last week of her just she has no idea
what she's saying in terms of the
history the reality the geopolitics or
anything those but what do you think we
do I mean I think most people again if
we go back to those percentages that you
were laying out earlier most people know
that Rashida Talib is not uh a
congresswoman because of her love of
America uh she announced she was going
to try to you know um impeach Donald
Trump the day he was elected I mean
that's slight different from what we're
talking about right now but the point is
she is going out of her way to support a
foreign terrorist organization like what
is our legal recourse here Beyond just
that hopefully the people of Dearborn
get rid of her which likely they are not
going to do like at what point do you at
what point do you cross a threshold
where we know that you know we've got
the wolves in the hen house well I mean
at this point I mean it's pretty obvious
that there are a lot of wolves in the
hen house the only question is how many
as far as what what has to happen I mean
Congress should expel her she lead she's
a Kamas supporter I I seem unaware of
any regulation that requires Congress to
keep among its members somebody who
overtly supports terrorist groups that
that burn babies rape women and kidnap
literal literal infants it seems to me
that that's a pretty good reason for
everybody in the house to unite in
expelling Rashida TB I mean that that
that seems Baseline to me the fact that
Democratic party won't do it is again
that goes back to their addictions to
the intersectional Coalition politics
they're they're afraid that if they do
that well they may lose a chunk of that
intersectional Coalition so you got to
keep the terrorist supporter around here
and we'll say some words about her we'll
say that she's bad and we'll say that
she's mean but we won't do the one thing
that actually would make sense which is
the person who supports Hamas probably
should not be sitting in the United
States Congress so I want to shift to
the president of the United States
because he went to Israel yesterday and
I think his statement when he gave his
first statement was actually pretty good
I think it was nice that he showed up to
to support Israel obviously uh but
here's a portion of uh his speech that
went a little sideways today I'm also
announcing $100 million in new US
funding for human Arian assistance in
both Gaza and the West Bank this money
will support more than 1 million
displaced and conflict affected
Palestinians including emergency needs
in
Gaza 100 million to Gaza and the West
Bank let's let's talk about them
separately for a second so first off the
idea that you're giving money to Gaza
means you're giving money to Hamas there
is no other ruling party there is no
other people that take the money and
funly dispense it um this doesn't seem
like a great idea and then we'll do the
West Bank separately yeah and I mean
obviously it's it's a horrible idea and
my favorite statement about this was
Tony blinkin the Secretary of State who
said yeah we're going to give a bunch of
Aid to to Gaza and if it's hijacked by
Hamas we will be the first to condemn it
it's like well that that's thank you
thanks that's that's awesome dude really
appreciate or that's like fan money
right it's it's the same thing right
we'll give you money it's totally
ridiculous it's absolutely ridiculous on
its face I understand the geopolitics of
what Biden is trying to do here what
he's trying to do is he's trying to
create a coalition of Arab governments
that are going to have some say in Gaza
Strip and attempt to get Hamas to turn
over the terrorists and then and then
take expulsion to Qatar or something in
return for for ending the the current
conflict I think that's what he's
probably trying to do to put the best
possible gloss on it is well you know if
if if America does this then you can see
that we're acting with Good Will Jordan
will come to the table Egypt will come
to the table cut some sort of deal over
who gets to run Gaza after all of this
is over the hostages get turned over
happy ending for everybody except for
the 1500 dead Jews uh that that would be
I think what what Biden is probably
trying to do right there that's like the
best interpret also why would you
possibly give a hundred million dollars
to terrorists I mean it's just it's
again it's part and parcel of this
idiocy inside the Biden Administration
you can pay off your enemies and
suddenly they become your friends
because they're eager for the cash or
alternatively Kamas just proved that
they would spend 20 years taking every
dollar poured into the Gaza Strip
billions and billions and billions of
dollars and instead of actually helping
their people they poisoned the aquafer
they took all of the water pipes and
turned them into Rockets they took all
the cement and built it into Terror
tunnels they built electricity and water
for you know the guys who are
underground right now but nothing for
the people above ground and then what
you're going to throw more money at that
so I mean that that's the situation in
in the Gaza Strip when it comes to the
West Bank judan and Samaria giving again
the question is giving money to whom the
Palestinian Authority is going to pay $3
million in stipend to the in Grants to
the families of the Hamas terrorists who
committed these murders there's still
pay for inside the Palestinian
Authority not not only that Palestinian
Islamic Jihad is the other governing
party in the so-called West Bank they
just fired a rocket that killed a bunch
of people at a hospital supposedly so
why where where exactly is that money
going again one of the biggest problems
here and this is the problem that Israel
faces on on all fronts and this is why
this is an existential crisis if Israel
does not take out Hamas successfully
that is going to embolden Terror groups
in Jud and Samaria the West Bank to then
commit acts of Terror against Jews
throughout the state of Israel Israel is
a tiny country people do people have
never been there do not understand what
we are talking about when you say things
like this is an existential threat
because they think well America's Giant
and large I mean if there was something
that happened in New Jersey would that
necessarily affect me in Florida Israel
in certain places is 9 miles wide
literally 9 miles wide tulkarm which is
the site of an ongoing operation by
Israeli police to stop terrorist
organization is located like eight and a
half miles from the Mediterranean Ocean
right now Israel is facing an
existential threat on its northern
border as well from Hezbollah which has
150,000 Rockets minimum pointed at the
North and center of Israel these are
highly sophisticated Rockets these are
not the dumb bombs that Hamas has been
sending into Israel the early estimates
are that if if Hezbollah were to get in
full scale it wouldn't be 1500 Jews it
would be 20,000 Jews de in like the
first week of a conflict so the notion
that Israel that we should be number one
signing checks to anybody who is in
League with Hamas or who's giving money
to Kamas or who is sympathetic to Hamas
is totally insane and then the notion
that Israel should not be able to finish
off Kamas is going to be so damaging for
Israel because again the reason Israel
has been able to maintain its presence
in the Middle East is because there is
only one coin of the realm in the Middle
East and that's strength it's the only
coin of the realm there's no such thing
as moral swas there's no such thing as
Mutual forgiveness and highness that is
not a thing that happens the reason that
Israel exists there is because of the
perception of Israel's military
invulnerability Israel does have an
incredibly strong military but what
happened on October 7th punctures the
notion that Israel is impregnable and
that is something Israel is going to
have to reestablish in short order or
it's going to be tested again and again
and again Ben I'm gonna have my guys put
the map up again because I'm glad you
mentioned the size because I know people
are confused about the politics around
this area uh but it's also the tiny size
as you're saying N9 miles wide if you
don't include the West Bank there as
people can see where Tel Aviv is but the
other point that I've been trying to
make and I I've been literally making
this point for years when and I'm not
the only one obviously when when these
outbreaks happen with Hamas can we go
back to the map one more time if you
look at the southern tip of Gaza there
there is a massive border with Egypt
that's Sinai next to it Sinai is way
bigger than all of Israel put together
uh it seems odd to me that nobody in the
International Community is calling on
Egypt to just open their borders stop
those crazy genocidal Jews from killing
all the Palestinians and let them move
to Sinai where basically nobody lives
and by the way Israel gave Sinai back to
Egypt in the name of Peace which they've
Bas you know had in essence for a couple
decades now Israel tried to give Gaza
back to Egypt and Egypt said hell no we
want no peace of Gaza Israel by the way
has tried to give back control of for
example cities like Janine to Jordan and
Jordan's like we don't want these people
are you out of your mind every time they
go into any country they then
destabilize the regime I mean it's very
easy to forget but Jordan itself
expelled 20,000 Palestinians and killed
3,000 Palestinian Ians in 1970 because
the population was so radicalized that
population then ended up moving to
Lebanon where they completely
destabilized a Christian State and
turned it into an Islamic State under
the opes of the Iranian government and
Hezbollah I mean it's there's a reason
why Egypt does not want this to happen
there are 21 Muslim countries in this
immediate Precinct and all of them have
come out in favor of the Palestinian
refugees and none of them have said they
will accept a single Palestinian refugee
and that is for two reasons one they
want the Palestinian refugees to
continue to be a weapon to be used
against Israel and two they don't want
those Palestinian refugees in their
country I mean people forget that in the
Syrian conflict there are millions and
millions and millions of syrians who
Moved abroad they're not asking to go
back to Syria because it turns out that
Syria is a horrible place to live 3.5
million syrians left Syria and ended up
in Turkey during the during the Syrian
conflict they the turkeyy has talked
about pushing them back into Syria
they're not doing it they're they're
still living there but when it comes to
the Palestinians in in the Gaza Strip
many of whom by the way do support Kamas
that doesn't mean that they deserve
what's happening to them but it does
mean that to pretend that this is a
governable population that is moderate
in nature that is not true there's no
evidence to to suggest that that is the
case whatever happens next is going to
have to require the involvement of the
Arab states surrounding and if it
doesn't then this conflict becomes
intractable and it just shows you that
the kind of challenge that Israel faces
again Israel got out of the Gaza Strip
because it did not want to govern the
Gaza Strip in 2005 it didn't want to
govern it so much that it let a a
terrorist group run the place for 20
years and then when that backfired now
Israel is forced back into it and now
they're being told by the Arab states
that they're not doing enough to save
civilians it's unbelievable
is the other part of this related to the
immigration thing and you mentioned how
many syrians are in Turkey but the
amount of people that we know that have
now come to Germany and to France and to
England and you see that reflected in
these insane Hamas protests um is the
next step on this I mean Jamal Bowman
the other day said we should start
talking about taking in Gaz and refugees
I'm very proud to live in the Free State
of Florida as everyone knows where Ronda
santis has said we should take in zero
that's it zero not one more um but
doesn't it feel like that'll be the next
move by the Democrats we we need to take
in 100,000 of these people it would not
be shocking to me at all if Democrats
start calling for that sort of stuff
outright I mean they they did so during
the Syrian conflict and when Donald
Trump said well we haven't vetted any of
these people nor could we V any of these
people they immediately called them a
racist because to even point out that
there may be some you know cultural
differences between impoverished radical
Muslims living in Syria and Americans
that that that that's that's a bridge
too far it doesn't matter that you now
have entrenched radical Muslim centers
in places like London in places like
Sweden in places like Germany well we're
supposed to ignore the evidence of our
own eyes and ears instead it's very very
offensive if Ronda santis points out
that the Palestinian population in the
Gaza Strip is anti-emetic I mean I'm
sorry to tell you this but the
population of the Gaza Strip is
anti-Semitic because they've been
indoctrinated for several Generations in
why the Jews are evil they literally
play it to small children they have TV
shows that are fully produced with
Mickey Mouse knockoffs telling kids to
kill Jews so again it's the West seeking
to Blind its own eyes I don't think
America's going to do something like
that I think even Joe Biden has enough
brain cells left to understand that
would be a horrible political move for
him but if there is a call for that it's
coming from the exact same place that we
were talking about earlier this sort of
peculiar Western narcissism that either
believes that everyone thinks like us or
from the coalitional left that says okay
well we can import these people and sure
they hate American values but hell so do
we so that's all right all right we've
only got a couple minutes left uh
because you're a busy guy you do you do
a show on the Internet or something what
is it that you do all day you do
something right um but you mentioned Joe
Biden and the brain cells here he is on
Air Force One I think this was leaving
Israel it's Anthony blink in the
Secretary of State behind him and and
just just watch
this virtually
every mass
shooting
every circumstance
where large number of people have been
victimized and lost I spoke
with I learned a long time ago what you
all learn
like when someone's going through
something that is beyond their
comprehension they felt they' had to go
through but they see someone who they
think understands or maybe they through
something not the same but
similar it gives them some sense of
hope and I always get criticized
sometimes on my stat when I go to these
an I stay for 3 to four hours to answer
all their
questions all right Ben we only got
about 5 minutes left so I don't think we
have to go into all the obvious stuff
about his cognitive uh impairment but
the specifics of seeing him in that
situation and blinking behind him
clearly like oh no here we go and then
you know they just want to pull him away
from the media in some ways is that what
this is all about he represents just a
deeply weak America and everyone knows
it and again I don't want to be
hypercritical of him in this moment
because I think they've basically been
good but but that he's the he's the um
the avatar for everything that's wrong
right now I mean listen they spent years
trying to make nights with with Iran
they sent hundreds of millions of
dollars to the Palestinian Authority and
Hamas and right now he's trying
correctly to present a deterrent to
Hezbollah getting in to Iran getting in
to this turning into a regional war and
there's only one big question in
everybody's mind which is how credible
is that threat and in order to make a
credible threat that if you get in we
will get in we will squash you like a
bug you can't look weak and it's very
difficult when the face to that is a
person who obviously looks physically
impaired I mean Joe Joe Biden looks weak
he looks like he can barely speak at
this point and again I'm like you I I
think that the the moves he's making
overall right now are correct putting
the aircraft carriers in the
Mediterranean to basically say tobah
stay out so Israel can do what it needs
to do that is the correct move to
prevent Regional War there are a lot of
kind of isolationists out there who are
like well isn't that going to get us
into World War II no it will get us into
World War II is if Hezbollah gets in and
then Syria gets in and then Iran gets in
and then Israel has to retaliate with
everything it has and then Russia gets
in in order to protect Iran that that
sort of chain of events is very easy to
foresee what stops all of that is
America saying don't go don't cross this
line because if you do we're going to
smack you like a bug the question is
whether people actually believe that
from Joe Biden and that is a really
really open question this the same guy
who cut and ran from Afghanistan this is
the same person who again was trying to
make nice with the Iranians five seconds
ago and was trying to hand them $6
billion doar and pretending that it
wasn't fungible and and that's the
person who is having very a very
difficult time physically even keeping
up with the demands of the job so listen
I hope that he's Stallard and I hope
that it's not a bluff but I think that
there are a lot of people who are asking
whether it is and you can see
why Ben we've been at this game together
in one degree or another for a long time
I it should not be another two years
before we do this publicly but uh I
think when we sat down once maybe the
first time you said something to me I I
was an atheist at the time and you you
were trying to bring me over to to the
the believer side of things to God and
everything else and I have to say I'm
I'm more of a Believer and I've been
trying to talk to God a little bit more
and listening to what he might be saying
than ever before in these in these crazy
times so I thank you my friend and and I
hope to see you soon now hang in there I
appreciate
it all right guys I'm just going to
finish up for for a couple minutes I've
actually got nothing else on the notes
or anything else uh but I I felt like
having been on was kind of the right the
right move today you know one of the
other things that's kind of going on
here beyond the the obvious stuff that
we just discussed all the the
geopolitics and the protests and the
craziness and the just the cultural rot
that has led to all of this is that it
is getting harder and harder and I it's
why I'm feeling like this like I always
feel a certain pressure I suppose to to
tell you the truth and to not lie about
things and to be clear and try to see
what my weak spots are and not suffer
from audience capture you know one of
the interesting things is you remember
like a month ago on this show for a
couple days in a row I kept saying how I
was worried about audience capture this
is something that I think a lot of guys
who do something like I do and they're
obviously hundreds or thousands of us at
this point to choose from uh can get
captured by the this the idea that oh
your audience thinks a certain thing and
if you keep going to that thing your
audience will grow or they will love you
more or they will donate more money or
they will click more or share more or
whatever and then in some ways that
feeds the craziness right because you
can always go to the base and maybe
going to the base all the time isn't the
best thing because it's not the truest
thing and it's not it's not really
what's right it's just it's just red
meat for everybody and about a month ago
I had a week having nothing to do with
any of this it was before all this where
I kept thinking about that a lot it was
just on my mind in general I wanted to
make sure that even if we were to look
at it through the context of the Trump
and Dan santis thing I think that's how
I was really talking about it like
obviously I think Dan santis would be
the next best president of the United
States uh but I didn't want and I knew
that some of my audience was angry at me
over that um but I wanted to just keep
telling people what I believe to be true
and then you can tune in and or not tune
in and you can be pissed at me or you
can like what I do or anything else but
in some ways the the Trump to Santa
thing seems like you know yesterday's
news Al together it obviously won't be
much longer uh but we have a much bigger
problem right now that I I'm finding it
very difficult to find people um that I
can watch that I think are trying to
make some decent sense of all this
obviously I think Ben is one of those
people I think Megan Kelly has really
shined as I mentioned I think Dan Dan
Bonino has done an absolutely great job
I hope that you guys think that I'm
doing a pre pretty decent job of this
and and and that you will continue to
call me out if I have blind spots or if
I lie to you or if a bomb goes off and I
tell you it was them and it turned out
to be the other guys that the next day
I'm not going to go on the show and lie
about it like Rashida Talib was standing
in front of the capital knowing that she
was just repeating another lie uh so we
we got a whole host of problems guys um
but humans have been through worse
humans have been through all sorts of
stuff right we've been through medieval
times and we've been through the
Holocaust and we've been through world
wars and genocides and all of those
things and I guess what the weird thing
is now is that we live in
such comfort in the west that it's sort
of what Ben was talking about like we
it's hard for us to really understand
that there are people out there that
really really don't like us that really
don't like our diversity of thought
right they don't like that people might
live next door to people think
differently than them or a different
religion or have some other Traditions
than they have and and it's hard to
really understand that they could be on
the March and yet they seem like they
are on the March so the question for all
of us is what will we do to defend the
United States what will we do to defend
the ideas that have become that that are
the jealousy of the world right it's why
everybody still wants to come here and
nobody's leaving why we've got these
open borders no one's going the other
way right like there aren't long lines
of people trying to get into Mexico me
or Canada they're all trying to get in
right and we really should think about
that and figure out how whatever you can
do in your life I think it probably
starts with spreading a little bit of
truth about some of this stuff because I
think we've laid out here and I've been
trying to lay out for the last two weeks
why this isn't just about this little
country in a in a weird little place
that's a that is a desert somewhere that
they made Bloom it's not just about that
it's it's much it's much bigger it's
about whether the West will decide to
stand up for itself or not that remains
to be seen uh all right we got a
postgame show coming up at Ruben report.
locals.com and uh we've got a day full
of stuff if I'm not mistaken what else
is happening oh tomorrow you know so one
of the things I want I didn't want to do
just purely like again what happened in
the Middle East and how many bombs went
off and everything else I didn't want to
do that uh for the round table this week
so I wanted to do what I did a little
bit there with Ben which was connecting
this to The Wider woke thing and how
it's obvious it obviously was going to
lead to where we are at right now so
James Lindsay who you guys all know who
who's been on the show many times uh
who's been probably the premier thinker
in terms of laying out what the goals of
the woke left the modern racists and and
the gender PE the gender confusing
people are what their plans are we've
got James Lindsay on and Melissa Chen my
friend Melissa Chen who's also been
really at the Forefront of of kind of
distilling this evil and showing us that
uh perhaps there's better way so they'll
be on the show tomorrow postgame show in
about 37 seconds 37 seconds Connor we're
going to hold out for an extra 7 seconds
can you do that for me Ruben report.
locals.com all right thanks
[Music]
everybody